well a week after the liberation of the
Ukrainian city of her son signs of the
Russian occupation are everywhere in the
city hundreds of people are reported to
have been detained or have gone missing
while Moscow was in control it's the
Sabbath for Orthodox Christian
worshipers seen here attending Sunday
mass in the city some parishioners told
journalists that under nearly eight
months under moscow's control they often
prayed for deliverance from Russian
forces
DW's Jan Phillip Schultz joins me now
from the Ukrainian Capital Kiev Jan
Philip there are reports about powerful
explosions around the area of Ukraine's
nuclear power plant zaprasia what do you
know about that
yes we have also heard about those
reports but they seem to refer to the
area around the nuclear power plant and
not to the premises of the power plant
itself Russian forces have been accusing
Ukraine all morning of selling the
region but those could be fake news
those could be even false flag attacks
as we have seen many times in the past
months I think what we have to do is we
have to wait about more information from
the international atomic energy agency
that is monitoring the situation very
closely at the moment
I'm going to bring up another Point here
Ukrainian authorities are now saying
some 700 bodies almost all of them
civilians by the way have been
discovered in newly liberated areas more
evidence they claim of Russian
atrocities what do you know
yes it's probably too early to speak
about concrete numbers and a lot of this
information coming out of the liberated
areas is still unconfirmed but indeed
Ukraine's prosecutor general just said
that they discovered hundreds of of dead
bodies in the past four weeks mainly
civilians and he also spoke about dozens
of facilities where civilians were
allegedly illegally detained some
colleagues just returned from Herson a
city that was liberated about a week ago
and they have endless stories of
maltreatment of civilians and even of
alleged torture chambers in the area but
just like in Butcher and urban and the
other places in the past months it will
still take a while until we get the full
picture which really happened in in the
recently liberated areas
that is a DW's John Philip Schultz in
Kiev many thanks to you sir